وكان ازمات السودان تطول ولا تخسر تتجدد
كل حين لكن بظروف مختلفه هذه المره اقلقت
كثير من المخابز ابوابها بعض 40 يوم من
اندلاع الحرب في الخرطوم الاختتال
والانتشار العسكري ادى لنفاذ الدقيق داخل
المخابز والى توقف الامداد الوقوف
والانتظار لساعات طويله بات هو السبيل
الوحيد المتاح للحصول على خبز والافران
كله هناك مقفل دقيقه
ما ما في دقيقه يعني
شغال في
الرابع هنا الصباح ليوم الليله الساعه
قريب الصلاه قربت يعني كل يوم انت بتصبح
الصباح انه الحكايه متازمه يعني متازيه
ومتزمه الافران ماشيه في تكفيل زياده كل
يوم
في ازمه بتاعه صفوف ثقيله فصاحب من الساعه
سته طبعا
يعني
لا يبدو ان هناك حلولا عمليه لصد النقص اذ
ان اغلاق المخابز ستواصل فيها كذا اوضاع
حسبما يقول اصحابها المشاكل في الدقيق
الغاز
ما في وجود الالغاز ولا ولا الدقيق ولا
على الخميره
في ظل شحي وصعوبه الحصول عليه لجا عددا من
السودانيين الى بدائل قديمه حلها تعوض
صعوبه الحصول عليه فقد تسيدت منتجات الذره
لعدد كبير من المواطنين
الرز والمكرونه والحاجات دي كلها
في الحاجات دي المهم كل شيء ما في الوضع
صعب جدا جدا
اقلقت كثير من مخابز الخرطوم ابوابها امام
المواطنين لكنهم يعملون رغم تطاول امض
الحرب ان تظل ابواب اخرى مفتوحه امامهم
لمنحهم قدره الاكمال والاستمرار شهد نادر
لقناته العربيه والحدث اندرمان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات